it's great to welcome to the program
today Cal Newport who is a computer
science professor at Georgetown
University also author of several books
including most recently digital
minimalism choosing a focused life in a
noisy world previously deep work which I
recently recommended to my audience Cal
it's so great to have you on I
appreciate it
well thanks for having me it's my
pleasure so I've been following with
great interest the sort of societal and
cultural impact of modern media social
media technology that includes smart
phones and Netflix and all sorts of sort
of on-demand entertainment and you've
also been writing extensively about this
for a long time I don't think it'll come
as a shock to my audience that I agree
with a lot of your conclusions many of
which we'll talk about momentarily but
when did you first sort of get tipped
off to the idea that there is something
going on here that is impacting how
people sort of go about their days and
get work done or don't get worked on or
relate to other people in the world like
how early on did you pick up on this
issue
well back in 2012 I had published a
career advice book called so good they
can't ignore you and one of the ideas in
that book is that getting really good at
rare and valuable skills was a huge
piece of leverage and craft in a career
that was really meaningful so after that
book came out my readers were asking me
okay well how do I do that
how do I become really good at things
that are rare and valuable and I started
looking into that question I started
coming up with this tension I would find
something that's important such as
concentration learning new skills
producing at a high level and every time
I couple of something important I would
find this technological foil that was
unintentionally making it harder to do
that and so my 2016 book deep work was
really about this tension between how
concentrating is becoming more important
in our economy at the same time that
technology in the workplace was making
us worse at concentrating and so that
book came out and then my readers pushed
back again and said yeah but what about
life outside of work we're feeling like
technology especially what's happening
on our smartphones is taking us away or
reducing the quality of what we're
trying to do with our life outside of
the
professional context so again that
pushed me into that topic for digital
minimalism and so this has been the
story of my writing life let's say over
the last seven years or so it's keep
coming up against these tensions between
humans striving to flourish and
unintentional consequences of technology
that are holding them back from it so
let's focus in a little bit first on the
deep work component and then in part two
we'll dig in more deeply into what you
outline in in digital minimalism I
thought before I read your books that I
was handling a lot of these issues
really pretty well I was sort of like
satisfied with what I felt was my
work-life balance my relationship to
technology the amount of time I was
spending on sort of what I would
consider to be like the core important
tasks for what I do which are
researching the stories that make it
onto onto my show preparing and actually
filming the show and when I read deep
work I realized a huge percentage of
what I'm doing is this so-called shallow
work which is everything from responding
to emails dealing with administrative
tasks and and sort of all of those
things that aren't really the core of
what it is that I'm doing for people who
who are not aware of of what you're
arguing
what percentage of of many jobs now is
consumed not by sort of like the core
deep work but by this shallow work that
you identify as not not sort of core to
what one is trying to achieve to produce
value I think for many knowledge work
positions these days accidentally we've
gotten to a place where the vast
majority of people's time is being spent
either on non deep activities or being
done somehow roughly in parallel with
the back tivities greatly reducing their
efficacy in other words I think we're
doing a really poor job right now
allocating cognitive resources in an
elite knowledge economy like we have in
the US the number one capital resource
is attention capital the ability of
human brains the human brains that you
employ to actually concentrate and
produce information with new value and
we're doing a terrible job right now at
getting the best return on that capital
investment and so even just having this
terminology there's a difference between
deep work we are trying to actually
tract maximum value from the brain
versus shallow work which is how you
keep the lights on in the trains run on
time just understand there's a
difference between those two allows you
to have these type of realizations that
wait a second we're paying all this
money to house all of these brains and
to put up you nice offices and
air-conditioned man heat I mean give
them benefits so that the brains can be
healthy and produce value and yet we're
then loud these brains to spend the vast
majority of their time doing sort of non
high-level non skilled sort of
administrative style work yeah I mean
it's I'm realizing that you know a lot
of this time you're you're doing all of
that stuff to sit around and and
effectively answer emails and be a
go-between between other other
individuals so at the very top level
obviously we can't go through everything
in an interview like this but one of the
things you talk about is very clearly
delineating when it is that you were
doing that shallow work and a lot of
professions you can't get rid of it
altogether but it seems that condensing
it and compartmentalizing it into
particularly planned and scheduled times
is is sort of one idea that can be
effective for a lot of people from a
very practical standpoint is that doable
for people in most professions I feel
like that's one of the most common
things people say when I tell them I'm
trying to do this they say sounds great
if you can do it but here's why it would
not apply to my particular profession
which I'm guessing you hear often I hear
it a lot and there certainly are
professions in which let's say
concentrated cognitive work what I call
deep work is not that important but I
also think that people vastly
overestimate the number of professions
for which that's actually true and what
I recommend is that people should have
clarity this is how much deep work I'm
doing this is how much non deep or
shallow work I'm doing and they should
have some sense of for my position what
is the optimal ratio in a normal week
what is the optimal ratio of deep work
hours to shallow work hours from the
perspective of what optimizes the value
I produce for the organization I think
people should have an answer to this
question I think people should be
discussing this question with their
supervisors or bosses if they work for
someone else I think people should be
measuring and seeing how well they're
coming up against this ratio now the
ratio is going to be different for
different people it can be different for
different jobs some jobs let's say
you're a novelist probably the ratio
should be almost a hundred percent deep
work and another jobs let's say you
lobbyists here in DC where I am well
maybe almost all of what you're doing is
just connecting to people and there's
very little deep work but you should
have an answer we can't blind ourselves
to how much deep work we're doing versus
how much sell and what would be better
and the feedback I'm getting from my
readers is that once you get
quantitative on this this is the ratio
that makes sense for my job here's where
I am there's a gap once you're once your
quantitative on this you see the stark
numbers this sparks a lot more cultural
changes than people assume is possible
now a lot of this also depends for
people who are not in a sort of
supervisor business owner or
entrepreneur role role but rather are
working for somebody else a big part of
this is as you mentioned having these
conversations with whoever is is kind of
monitoring your time because the
expectations from sort of modern
employers often would create a problem
for a lot of people if they were saying
hey you know half the day I'm gonna try
to do three hours for example or four
hours but you suggested if I recall
correctly maybe sort of the max for this
deep work that someone may be able to
get done in a normal day a lot of this
has to do with the culture in which
people are working does it not it does
but we think that these cultures are
entrenched and are immutable but the
reality is often that they're arbitrary
and emergent and are much more malleable
than we think once we actually come at
them precisely so here's a classic story
that I heard after my book came out I
was someone who was in marketing for a
Silicon Valley firm so he wrote white
papers which are incredibly complex and
really benefit from deep work and so he
went to his CEO and said okay here's
what deep work is here's what shallow
work is what ratio of deep to shallow
work makes the most sense for my job now
he clarified before he did this he was
very nervous because this organization
had a CELAC culture in which if you did
not respond to slack right away you were
seen as ironically slacking off but he
had this conversation with his CEO and
he said it became almost immediately
clear that it would be crazy for the
answer to be zero they decided that
50-50 made sense and it took about a
week for them to change this he just
told his team these two hours in the
morning these two hours in the afternoon
that's when he is doing his deep work
he's not to be interrupted don't expect
a response it took people about a week
to get used to it and now suddenly this
has a 50/50 deepest shallow ratio with
complete by in front his team in the CEO
and it took him only at let's say a week
to actually change where before he had
this conversation he was convinced this
is a slack place this is a slack office
if you're not responding it'll never
work so I think we think these cultures
are there for a reason and they're
entrenched and our bosses are going to
insist on them you push a little deeper
and you realize often nobody is happy
with them and a great change is possible
as long as you're clear pause that have
been quantitative about why you're
making the change yeah after reading
deep work and a bunch of articles about
slack I immediately cancelled slack
fully and told all of my employees but
we're simply not using it and in fact I
went further I said hey you know I I'm
really going to be trying to spend most
of the morning on on what is I think is
the most important thing which is really
researching and preparing for the show
so I will check my email when I get to
my desk and I will not look at email
again for several hours if there's a
real emergency text me I'm not going to
ignore you right I mean these are
employees and to some degree I need to
be available but if it's not an
emergency you're not going to hear back
from me and very quickly everybody just
does seem to adjust so a lot of it is as
you're saying what you think is
necessary versus what what is sort of
actually necessary in many cases and and
along those same lines I'm curious is
there a way or do you have any anecdotes
about how we can quantify the effect of
these longer periods of concentration on
productivity because I think one of the
biggest misconceptions is that one gets
more done by switching between tasks and
sort of covering a lot of basis in a
less in a less deep way but
qualitatively and quantitatively it
actually seems counter to the reality
how can we sort of explain how the focus
for longer periods of time
quantitatively actually allows people to
get more done well I think a mindset
shift that helps here is thinking about
efforts in terms of let's say learn
skilled applied so if you're if you're
answering emails or jumping on calls or
moving things back and forth and
PowerPoint these are all activities that
don't actually require the application
of sort of hard-won or elite level
skills and so the value they're
producing is not actually that high as
compared to let's say you're thinking
very deeply on researching a piece or
gonna do for your show something that
you're uniquely qualified to do that
builds on a large foundation of
experience it requires a lot of
concentration that is going to produce
much more value because that's much more
rare or hard to do and so I have this
trick in the book where I talk about
quantify the activity you're about to do
with how many hours would it take to
train a smart recent college grad to do
what you're about to do and if the
answer is I could probably train them in
a few hours to do this then that's
probably not an activity that's going to
be massively value producing but if on
the other hand it's well it probably
would take in four or five years of
training and work at experience or if
they could even approximate what I'm
about to be doing you're getting a much
higher return on the cognitive resource
for that activity and so I think this
mindset shift is crucial
shallow work is necessary to keep things
running but it doesn't produce a ton of
value deep work is the actual you know
the wrench is on the car building the
thing that's going to go off the
assembly line to be sold type activities
and once you have that mindset shift you
begin to worry about shallow work and
how much time your employees are
spending on it and and really start to
focus on the deep work because that's
what produces the value so in part two
we'll dig in much more deeply to digital
minimalism which is the latest book but
to start getting us in that mindset and
transitioning into that can you talk a
little bit about what sort of
psychological problems or emotional sort
of issues can arise when we become
attached to this type of quote
multitasking which I know we you and I
actually take issue with the idea that
it's actually multitasking rather than
switching between things really quickly
what are the issues that can develop
longer-term in terms of concentration in
terms of emotional issues as well well
there's a few issues one is context
switching so switching to an inbox and
then back to a primary task reduces your
cognitive capacity and that effect takes
a while to clear out and so if you are
constantly having to jump over and check
an inbox or a slack channel then return
to what you're doing you're not really
single tasking this context switching is
having a huge cycle
to call burden on what you're actually
able to produce and so it's like buying
a fancy piece of equipment in the man in
a factory but then allowing sand to
build up in its gear so it can't
function is hard it's a real crisis I
don't think we understand it there's
also a social drag on a workplace that's
built on constant ongoing conversation
our brains are sophisticated social
computers that evolved in a context
where we didn't have digital inboxes and
so you might know rationally that those
600 unread emails in your inbox are
different then let's say a member of
your tribe sitting across from the fire
trying to get your attention
but there's a deep part of your brain
that doesn't see that distinction and it
sees it as social obligations that you
are ignoring which is according to your
brain a crisis and so that makes us
anxious and uneasy about all this the
communication that we're not answering
it makes us check things more
compulsively and then finally we have a
long term ability and our ability
degradation our ability to concentrate
if your brain gets used to constantly
switching between different stimuli when
it comes time to really lock in and use
those neurons to produce information
that's valuable for you and your
organization you're gonna be worse at it
just like if you're a professional
athlete and you're smoking outside of
outside of the games and you're training
it's going to have an effect on the
field same thing if your whole life is
constantly moving back and forth between
professional and personal in boxes and
screens and apps your brain is going to
get worse and worse at actually locking
in and producing new and valuable
information that's actually a great
place to pause our conversation with Cal
Newport we've been talking about two of
his books digital minimalism as well as
deep work which is now three years old
we will continue the conversation with
him on tomorrow's program and dig
further into digital minimalism the
latest book we're continuing our
conversation today with Cal Newport who
is a computer science professor at
Georgetown University also author of
several books including the brand-new
digital minimalism choosing a focused
life in a noisy world Cal I've already
adopted a lot of the techniques that you
talk about in the book and I even not
only did I tell my staff that I was
doing this I actually told my audience
as well I told my audience I am
significantly going to be limiting my
engagement on Twitter partially because
when you do political stuff
it's extraordinarily toxic and mostly
negative anti-semitic comments in my
particular case but for anybody I would
argue what you were talking about in
digital minimalism would really serve
both attention spans as well as just
sort of general emotional health so
let's start there what is the most
important way that we should understand
the effect of this endless scrolling
what I call the operant conditioning
variable rewards mechanism that social
media has why is that bad for us well
there's a couple things going on one is
these apps have been engineered to
foster compulsive use and so what
happens is at first it becomes an easy
distraction and then over time it
becomes a replacement for other
activities that are more meaningful and
more satisfying and therefore more and
more of your discretionary time gets
funneled into what are essentially these
virtual data factories where you sit
here scrolling helping the revenue
numbers of three or four companies while
other parts of your life that are more
important or more meaningful get
neglected and then there is the actual
content and engagement when you're
actually looking at these screens some
of what you do on these screens is fine
it's good for you I mean there's nothing
specifically negative about let's say
sending a comment to a relative of yours
about what they're up to
but because the algorithms behind a lot
of these news feeds or Twitter feeds are
optimized for engagement there's this
sort of darker side of what you're
actually looking at where just like you
talked with your experience and Twitter
that it pulls you towards extremism it
pulls you towards darkness it pulls you
towards a place of feeling socially
uneasy or unhappy which eventually makes
these things I like to think of them as
unhappiness generating machines there
are people who will put in place sort of
protocol like a weekly digital Sabbath
on Saturday I don't touch any of my
technology and/or I don't look at any
social networks or when I'm on vacation
I will get completely off of them or
whatever the case may be the problem I
have with that or the concern I have is
that it's sometimes used to justify
really unhealthy social media behavior
behaviors all of the other time because
you're saying hey listen Saturdays I'm
doing the thing that I think is better
for me or once a year I'm doing this
other thing how important are these sort
of every once in a while cleanses so to
speak versus just kind of like
maintaining healthy habits throughout
the year I think they're a terrible idea
I mean if you want my opinion if I had a
friend let's say who during the week was
abusing alcohol and was causing lots of
negative impacts in their life if they
came to me and said don't worry I have
this great plan I'm not gonna drink on
Saturdays you know I would say I think
you're missing the bigger problem here
the fact that you have something that's
such a negative force in your life that
you feel the need to schedule escapes
from is perhaps evidence that this is a
problem that needs a more systematic
solution which is why in my book I talk
about a digital declutter as opposed to
a digital detox I think people in the
substance abuse community for example
are really upset about the way that the
word detox has been co-opted into this
digital world to mean something that's
really different than the original
meeting which is just let's take a break
from something's giving us trouble I
talked in terms of decluttering because
when you're decluttering you're not
taking a break from all of the extra
stuff you have in your house you're
getting rid of it and I think that's
what we really need the idea of turning
off notifications from apps I mean is
that does that even register as a
significant change that people can make
or is it just not nearly anything
basically what I discovered is the
smaller hacks like notifications making
your screen grayscale moving where your
apps are into folders on the second
screen if your iPhone or these digital
wellness tools where you see like a tree
that's dying or something every time you
pick up your phone they're not cutting
it I think the the cultural and
technological forces that are drawing
people back to the screen to mush and
make it unhappy are way too strong to
throw assorted hacks and tricks at it
and this has been my observation we've
tried this for about five or six years
now and it's really not working there
are studies that claim to be able to
assess the sort of degree of negative or
positive impact of different online
platforms there's one that's been talked
about quite a bit which says of all the
online platform
that were looked at YouTube was the only
one that seemed to have like a net
benefit for people in terms of
well-being and that every other one with
Instagram being the absolute and total
worst have a net negative impact on
people's emotions and psyche etc what's
your sense of sort of looking at the
nitty-gritty of these individual
platforms or do you think that that kind
of misses the boat no I don't think it
does and so if you I mean if you take a
minimalist approach to these
technologies which is what I suggest it
says you start with identifying what
really matters to you what you want to
spend your time on what you value and
then you work backwards and say is there
some way to deploy technology that's
going to give me a big win on one of
these particular values and you ignore
everything else and so depending on what
those values are there may be a very
specific technology maybe even a
technology that makes some people really
unhappy that works for you so a common
example I came across for example were
visual artists it turns out if you're a
visual artist what you need that the
main fuel for your work is creative
input you have to see other work from
other artists in a similar type of genre
and Instagram has been great for this so
now for the first time if your visual
artist you can look at other artists
works remotely without having to live in
one or two cities that happens to have a
major gallery scene so it's been a
powerful democratizing force so if
you're a visual artist the careful use
of Instagram let's say every week expose
yourself to a carefully curated list of
artists is very positive on the other
hand if you're you know say 22 year old
college grad kind of unhappy and adrift
Instagram could be a massive source of
negative energy and distraction and so I
don't like to think about good
technologies and bad technologies I like
to think about good uses of your time
good values and bad and putting the
technology to work for the former along
those lines you talk in in both digital
minimalism and deep work I think
although I'm going sort of for memory
here but the power of sometimes just
saying no and you describe something
that I encounter a lot which is I'll get
a request in my email and I really do
think of every email I get as a request
on my time right that that's the sort of
starting point request where hey David
would you be willing to participate in
some kind of six person
or whatever and really the answer is
just like no the correct answer is no
the right answer given where I am at any
particular point in time in my career in
personal life is no but there's some
combination of like guilt and the maybe
the fear of missing out I'll sort of say
no but also say but what I can do is
give you some ideas for good questions
for the panel for example and what I'm
effectively doing is volunteering myself
to do something where I'm losing all of
the possible benefit of being involved
but still committing some of my time
talk a little bit about the hesitancy
that society has bred into us to be
afraid or hesitant to just say no when a
straight no is really kind of the right
answer for us well part of this is an
unintentional consequence of introducing
low-friction digital communication into
the world a lot of our issues with
technology in general are unintentional
because we take things that have been
evolved into us in another context and
we introduce these new tools and so in a
tribal context if it's here's my tribe
and there's ten of us we're wired to be
very wary of social reciprocity someone
else in the tribe says hey can you help
me whatever carry my Spears over to her
hunting the mastodon you probably say I
probably should do that if I can just
like you would if a family member wanted
your help in the morning to you know
with with something just going on
because in small tribal context social
reciprocity is important for knitting
together the social fabric
now when you introduce into the picture
the sort of universal low friction
digital communication like email which
means sort of anyone in the country can
now send you a message and try to
request some of your time and attention
we still have that same instinct to do
social reciprocity but it doesn't scale
because now there's hundreds of
thousands of people now in this tribe
who could be making these requests and
so what we really have is this collision
on our Paleolithic social instincts
versus our technological digital world
and they're clashing and these clashes
cause a lot of the problems we have and
when it comes to this particular issue
we do want to help because that is our
instinct but once we get rid of this
friction probably the right framework is
Kant's categorical imperative right the
way that he tried to build up morale
from scratch he said the real question
was what happens if i take this specific
case and i scale it out to a universal
rule is that tractable and once you
start thinking that way you see the
problems with let's say saying yes to
someone who has a request for you to be
on a panel or do a 20-minute phone call
that request itself is perhaps small but
if you scale up to the general question
of what would happen if I said yes to
all of those you would have no time left
and so we have to basically build a new
philosophy from scratch like Kant was
trying to in the 19th century just to
deal with this new social reality yeah
and well you actually take it even
further in some cases which is straight
up don't respond to email and you talk
about situations in which there may be
some short term a negative impact maybe
somebody thinks less of you if you
ignore their email but that it's it's
important in a sense to set expectations
based on what is scalable and and that
it's it's okay in a sense to choose that
there are swathes of types of emails
that you simply shouldn't respond to but
the obvious question when people hear us
talk about that will be will that not
bring negative repercussions over the
long term you argue that it really won't
well what I've discovered is
expectations tend to trump accessibility
and we don't always realize this and so
as an author for example if you go to my
Arthur website and go to the contact
page I don't have a general use email
address I have some specific email
addresses for particular purposes and I
have what I call a cinder filter with
each which is just a little bit of text
it says here's what this message is for
and here's what you should expect and
that text says for basically all of
these don't expect a response now my
worry was okay maybe this is going to
upset people because I'm no longer as
accessible but it turns out that it
doesn't because what people care about
more is expectations so they're not
expecting a response and so they're not
that upset when they don't get one and
the converse of that is when I do
respond to someone it seems like it's an
unusually positive event and so I think
we over value accessibility and
undervalue what people really want is
some sort of expectation some sort of
consistency about should I expect a
response or not are you going to read
this or you not shall you even send this
in the first place we need to do more
work I think putting guards filters and
information around our communication
channels and get away from the sort of
incredibly
low-friction just anyone can reach me at
any time about anything type of world
which causes all this confusion so to
kind of wind down our conversation with
what maybe is one of the bigger meta
questions about all of this material if
indeed a technology continues going in
the same direction that it has been if
there's more sort of integration between
the human body and a lot of these
technologies as some futurists although
not all but believe there will be will
the type of approach that you're
suggesting be practical if someone wants
to live I guess it what we would call
like a normal person and I know that
that's an extremely stigmatizing and and
heavy sort of loaded term but I think
for our purposes you sort of know what I
mean will all of this become impossible
if technology continues going in the
direction it's been going well my
personal sort of futurist hypothesis is
that we're gonna see the opposite trend
happening I think one of the biggest
impact applications that we're gonna see
if artificial intelligence that we're
not really talking that much about is
that it's going to offload quite a bit
of the sort of shallow administrative
communication type stuff that takes up
so much of our especially professional
lives the model that a lot of AI large
AI players are thinking about is really
the chief of staff model where I have a
chief of staff my sort of Leo Leo
McGarry to my Jed Bartlet from the West
Wing like a presidential chief of staff
you have one everyone has one but it's
implemented by AIS those AIS are talking
to each other preserving us to use our
brains more focused on the things that
our brains do well sort of here's what
you should be working on right now all
the information is here think hard about
it provide something good the AI will
take care of it and so I think we're
actually going to see in the future a
significant decrease in the amount of
time we spend let's say doing shallow
communication back and forth and a
significant increase in the time we
spend actually thinking hard because
from an economic point of view that is
just a much much larger return on the
capital investment in human brains if
you can get human brain spend the most
of their time thinking hard about things
that only human brains can do minimize
the context switching minimize the time
loss to having to answer emails from HR
or setting up meetings or sitting back
and forth Google invites you take that
all off the plate you're going to get a
huge increase in the amount of value
that you get out of this
particular capital investment and so I
see a future where let's say email or
slack are going to be seen as relatively
primitive tools that we have to deal
with while waiting for our tech to get
where it really needs to get to support
a thriving knowledge economy well that
is a that is a nice optimistic note I
feel like to end what would often are
sort of dystopian feeling conversations
we've been speaking with Cal Newport
who's a computer science professor at
Georgetown University make sure to check
out his latest book digital minimalism
choosing a focused life in a noisy world
Cal really appreciate your time today my
pleasure